hi I'm Erik Bosse I'm Philip Molina and
this is a breakdown of Game of Thrones
the season 7 finale the dragon and the
freaking wall guys oh man this was so
fast
this isn't there is so much to break
down though all the details that you
guys might have missed so the biggest
moment of this season finale obviously
is the collapse of the freakin wall this
episode actually uses the opening images
and that scene ends up being a mirror of
the closing moments foreshadowing what's
gonna happen later right so notice how
the unsullied in this scene line up by
the thousands they're cold-eyed waiting
without emotion at a different wall in
this case the walls of King's Landing
just like the army of the Dead does at
the end of the episode right meanwhile
two guys who narrowly escaped a recent
battle looked down on them worried here
at Jaime and Bronn later
berrak and torment and then as they're
looking down at them we see the invaders
pouring in from the tree line and in
both cases the invasion is announced by
the blowing of a horn
[Music]
so what is this episode saying by
comparing the unsullied army with the
army of the dead in both cases they're
an incorruptible legion who take orders
from just one figure and it's a mystery
why these soldiers fight if they don't
have their own desires behind it yeah
and that makes them even more of a
terrifying existential threat to these
people right and we knew that Dani
granted the unsullied their freedom so
deep down they're probably fighting for
some version of love and that is what
makes them human but meanwhile the white
walkers don't have that drive and that's
what makes them even scarier now notice
bran and Jaime's dialogue here and
without Cox you wouldn't find me
fighting in an army if I had no [__] uh
yeah we're men without [__] we made the
joke before you could beyond the obvious
dick jokes Braun and Jamie here
discussing what the point is of fighting
it's actually similar to the
conversation that John and Barrack had
last episode it's interesting that Jamie
by the way brings up that gold and
family are reasons to fight because both
of those are rewards that were kind of
driving him this season but ultimately
left him empty-handed
instead he says may be useful to me yeah
so Jamie's conclusion here is that it's
not family that motivates soldiers to
fight ultimately it's hockey's selfish
thinking if you remember the war that
preceded the events of the show Robert's
rebellion that came down two [__] in
the end Rhaegar and Lyanna loved each
other
Robert was jealous so he fought for this
life until the world had changed they
are all actually really being driven by
their gods let's move on to John and
tiering in the rest walking to the
King's Landing dragon pit now Jorah
explains why the dragon pit was created
with this line dragons don't understand
the difference between one's bears and
what isn't land livestock children
letting them roam free around the city
was a problem right the episode is
titled the dragon and the wolf so
immediately we got to start thinking of
those as metaphors and in that way it
gives us a new context for what it means
to be a dragon what it means to be a
wolf dragons are selfish they fight for
themselves and wolves are better at
sharing resources and responsibilities
fighting for the pack as a whole for the
survival of a family
so in this episode some characters are
acting more like dragons other
acting more like wolves we're gonna
actually go through who's acting like
who later on right now Jorah and Tyrion
touch on the history of this place the
dragon pit and there's way more of a
symbolic backstory to the dragon pit in
the ax Song of Ice and Fire books though
let's quickly talk about all this
interesting stuff with our segment well
in the books books okay so the dragon
pit was constructed by Danny's ancestor
maegor the cruel he's the younger son of
Aegon the conquerer he sat on a gonzaga
blarin the dread he burned step to the
freakin ground which essentially
declared that a dragon pit is gonna be
constructed in its ashes because these
are your new gods now that's a pretty
badass thing to do right this structure
was a massive dome that the Targaryen
locked their dragons inside until
eventually generation after generation
the Dragons were smaller and weaker and
then this angry mob burned into the
ground and killed the five Dragons that
were inside of it so dragon puppies so
in that context the dragon pit is the
perfect neutral ground for this summit
between warring factions like notice
this line from Danny later this place
was the beginning of the end for my
family yeah she's right the pit
represents both the rise and the fall of
a Targaryen power we see this both with
Danny's powerful arrival on the back of
the largest dragons since balerion the
dread in the pits heyday but also in a
later scene when Daenerys holds this
tiny jawbone of the weakest dragon at
the end of that lineage so it's that
moment that causes Danny to reconsider
the benefits of being a dragon they
noticed the Valyrian words that she
speaks to John Jesus was Dario's ghost
old dragon is not a slave these are the
same words that she said to was it
kraznys in esta por right before she
tricked him and burned him alive
sad rhesus boost arias goes down
now in this scene this phrase has a
different meaning
Daenerys feels trapped herself kind of
like a slave she can't use her dragon to
torch Searcy like she did her past
enemies conquering isn't peacemaking and
she's now kind of lamenting how her
family past time of conquering and
burning their enemies eventually
actually leads to their very own
destruction so right here in this moment
she's being shrunken down to this tiny
little dragon skull she isn't any more
special than any of the other leaders
there in fact the word she uses about
her Targaryen ancestors are actually
about herself in the present we want
extraordinary without them we would just
like everyone else another detail that
we like from these scenes obviously came
from brick and bran you can suck his
magic cut later so even though this
seems really obvious you can actually
take it two different ways depending on
who exactly he's talking about in that
moment like for instance he could be
talking about that famously magical
piece of wood between Podrick legs that
left all the ladies satisfied or he
could be talking about that myth from
season five remember that slaver thought
that dwarves penises have a special
quality about them Welsh cook has magic
powers I guess it really is all about
[__] in the end right moving on once
they enter the dragon pit we get this
moment between Tyrion and hound and
every bad idea sometimes to come behind
it and some again come to help them see
it through now Tyrion is obviously
referring to Cersei and the mountain
here who appears in the next shot but if
you think about it it's also applies to
the mountains actions in the past right
remember he carried out the plans of
Tywin Lannister he fought for the crown
against Oberyn Martell Tyrians champion
in the trial by combat he also led Tywin
sacking of King's Landing where he
murders Elia Martell and her children
and that's what ultimately turned Dorne
against the Lannisters now the set
design of this dragon pit definitely
seems to be inspired by some real-life
ruins from our world so let's talk about
these parallels by diving deep into the
annals of history okay so this pit is
modeled on the Coliseum of Rome it has
this stadium style rose and a crumbling
facade just like that Coliseum does also
notice that in this center of the pit
and of the ruins the Roman Coliseum also
had pits that led underground they were
used to transport wild animals and it
out quickly so in this case
this could be used for a similar purpose
to feed the Dragons like a little baby
goat gets shoved in through there or
maybe a way to escape if you piss off
your dragon now of course the Colosseum
was built for the purpose of gladiator
combat as a spectator sport so it's
fitting that we get this moment between
two of Game of Thrones biggest gladiator
figures the Clegane brothers primarily
shameful it didn't exactly happen but
let's face it this show has pretty much
kept building this up between each other
like it's a freakin WWE match in fact
yeah let's actually merge the history
segment that we're doing now with
another segment we like to do here under
the influence there yeah there it is so
yes this moment definitely seems
influenced by one of the most famous
films to take place in the Roman
Colosseum really Scott's gladiator yeah
I guess if you noticed the Hound is
making the epic promise to his brother
who he still hates or burning his face
as a boy you know who's coming for you
that's a lot like the way that the
gladiator Maximus threatened
what's-his-face
Commodus is Commodus joaquin phoenix and
i will have my vengeance in this life or
the next but he leaves all the fans
desperate for blood in that moment
promising an inevitable collision
between those two kind of forces of
nature that's what happened to us we got
blue balls and a Coliseum that's the
reference by influence okay let's move
on to another section here guys we gotta
talk about the music of this episode
Ramin Djawadi composed new versions of
the themes that we've heard before a
bunch of times and he's using them to
tell a story about how each of these
characters are now colliding into each
other and ultimately changing yeah
remember at the top of the episode we
heard these deep bass notes of the House
Targaryen theme with a choral chant over
it
and that merged with the song of the
rains of castamere which of course is
the Lannister song as the focus shifted
inside the walls
so the music starts by establishing
Targaryen 's and Lannister's as mortal
enemies at each other's throats right
and here in the dragon pit gelati
features several main themes to convey
that dramatic shift that keeps happening
like it starts actually with the main
Game of Thrones theme song as they enter
the pit but you can notice the melody is
incomplete
[Music]
the last couple notes are missing yeah
just like how sir see engineers are
missing from this summit we don't know
yet what it'll sound like when all these
players complete the overall melody but
then when both of these Queens do arrive
they are accompanied by their power song
Cersei enters to the light of the seven
the music of course that scored her
destruction deceptive baler last season
finale and then when Daenerys arrives we
have the House Targaryen theme
[Music]
and then finally during the whole white
freaky demonstration thing the music
actually shifts to an eerie version of
the white Walker melody but if we don't
win this fight the music's a bit softer
and more understated than the other ones
are but the tone gives new context for
the debate this isn't about who has the
louder more impressive song this quieter
score is actually now more powerful it's
that slow coldness of death that feels
actually dangerous now later we hear the
rains of castamere a second time it's a
more threatening cover when Tyrion meets
with his sister Cersei and we don't know
the full extent of these Lannister
siblings conversation actually talk more
about that later but notice when Cersei
returns we finally hear the main game of
Thrones theme it's complete I expect not
cool our banners all of them
so yeah now after all these key players
have collided this is the symphony that
they play together but actually notice
that it still sounds different from the
main theme song
perhaps you'll remember I chose to help
but no promises or assurances from any
of you that's because it's a false
agreement right Cersei doesn't intend to
honor this deal here so the version of
the theme that we hear now is in a minor
key representing this overall failure he
was giving it away the whole time there
was also one popular melody that was
kind of missing from the sequence the
House Stark theme right we actually hear
that later with Sansa and Arya and the
snows fall and the white winds blow the
lone wolf dies but the puck slides but
notice that the violin melody has this
added folksy bend to the final few notes
I miss him
which again that's that idea that he's
evolving the music as the characters are
evolving and so now the Starks have a
changing power dynamic they still had
that same pack mentality but now they
have the families run by these women
yeah they've had this nonlinear journey
both of them that has led them back home
so naturally the House Stark theme has
its own new flourish and actually the
music at the very end of the episode is
kind of the most evolved much darker
version of the main game of Thrones
theme song
[Music]
yeah by breaking the wall the night King
has changed the map of Westeros
permanently so the composer takes the
music we usually hear when we see the
map the opening credits and transforms
it into this haunting upside down
version so moving on this episode was
directed by Jeremy Podesta who also
directed the season premiere and that's
something with Rose keeps doing by the
way as they let directors pair up
episodes and then you get to realize
like oh they making call back to their
own thing so one thing he did in that
episode was hide subtextual
conversations beneath the dialogue told
through the eye lines and reaction shots
that are all kind of miscible moment
yeah he actually does it again this
episode the showrunners brought up this
example of how complicated the reaction
shots were planned out this moment
between Cersei Brienne and Jaime Cersei
clears a brand
she's clearly like jealous that she and
Jamie had some sort of strong
relationship those was just based on
mutual respect yeah and then Bryan's
eyes are nervously darting over to Jamie
she clearly doesn't get in the middle of
this love triangle between these two
Jamie has everywhere he looks down he's
avoiding eye contact with his sister and
then Cersei glares at Jamie about to say
something about his emotional affair
okay before the dragon cuts him off
also in this thing you notice there's an
important moment between Tyrion and the
Greyjoy's you're the smallest concern
here do you remember when we discussed
fourth jokes
he's wasn't even good so technically
here Tyrion is referencing in that
moment with beyond back in season six
everyone who makes a joke about a
twelves type thinks he's the only person
ever to make a joke about the dwarfs
height moving on to the Lannisters this
episode shows what was left of the
Lannister pact that is all broken up and
it all starts with this really tense
reunion between Cersei and Tyrion yeah
notice what Cersei says about Daenerys
here I shouldn't be surprised I suppose
she's your kind of woman a foreign [__]
who doesn't know her place she's
actually referencing shade which obvious
is a sore subject for Tyrion Shaye was
foreign she wasn't from Westeros and
Tyrion snuck her up in the red cape as a
hand maid she didn't know her place she
ultimately also turned against Tyrion
and then testified against him and then
he murdered her so yeah it's not the
best memory for him to have died
compared to yeah Cersei is basically
telling Tyrion that likeshe Daenerys
doesn't really care about him and might
betray him if she's ever in her interest
now I want to talk about real quick that
moment where Cersei places our hand
her outer womb tyrion cuts her off and
he calls up the fact that she's pregnant
but i think he actually figured out
before that moment ya notice when he
places the wine in front of her she
doesn't drink it now tyrion knows how
much the two of them love wine so they
can only be one reason why Cersei would
not be drinking she's hungover okay so
this scene cuts off mid conversation and
later Cersei comes back to Daenerys and
John and declares that she's willing to
go along with their plan now a lot of
you were asking what really was going on
here later we actually learned that
Cersei is double-crossing them but what
did Tyrion say to Cersei to get her to
seemingly agreed to this plan in the
first place what happened in those
moments we didn't see we have some
deeper thoughts on this so let's dive
into theory time so what would Tyrion be
able to promise Cersei that would at
Linda's moment at least be something
that she would agree to remember he did
just learn that Cersei was pregnant
so could tyrion have made a secret pact
with his sister that if she would allow
her forces to join with Danny and jaws
he'd guarantee that that child would
make it into the line of succession
after Danny's gone yeah basically
promise that whatever happens the next
king or queen of Westeros would still
have Lannister blood remember last
episode Tyrians main concern was setting
in place a line of succession a new
system of government entirely to take
over after Daenerys is gone this plan
would basically kill two birds with one
stone form also it could explain why he
has that weird concerned look later in
the episode we went over some alternate
theories in Westeros weekly you can go
watch but if it's because of this secret
pact then when Danny and John are
hooking up if she actually isn't barren
and they do have a child
well that would spoil his whole thing he
just did with Cersei yeah a secret pact
might also explain why later she says
this to Jaime
I always knew you would this sheep it is
madness so notice actually leaves Tyrion
out of that suggesting that there may
have been some cleverness from Tyrion
behind the scenes that we didn't see
it's weird let us know what you think
about it in the comments all right
coming out of theory time later in this
episode Cersei reveals her true
intentions to Jaime to hold back her
forces and use a golden company to fight
whatever's left of Dany in Jon's army
after the White Walkers
now notice how just like Tyrion earlier
Jaime bares his sister to use the
mountain to kill him
and it comes really close both times but
also both times Circe backs down yeah so
why did she do this what with Tyrion
Cersei knows that killing him will spoil
any plan she has to screw over Danny in
the long run like she needs to keep him
alive if she wants to trick Danny into
trusting her
but with Jaime Circe's reason I think is
more emotional Jaime's the only part of
her that is still related to her heart
so to kill him would be to kill that
part of herself and the father of her
unborn child so maybe she's kind of like
we still have a chance together maybe
now Jamie and Cersei cease relationship
in this episode is modeled on a famous
work of Shakespeare and actually if
Shakespeare was a big influence on a lot
of characters this episode the guy
pretty much wrote every story that could
be written so then let's dive into
Shakespeare did it Shakespeare did it
okay so earlier in the episode we see an
example of that Shakespearean influence
with Joran Greyjoy actually because
remember how he had that interesting
kind of cowardly reaction to the white
I've been around the world I've seen
everything things you couldn't imagine
in this this is the only thing I've ever
seen that terrifies me now obviously he
could be acting there like we did learn
later that he's not actually retreating
to the Iron Islands but sailing to ask
those for Cersei pick up golden company
but I think he is legitimately pretty
afraid of resurrected corpses or the
idea but ya notice how only the mountain
seems to be able to keep him in line
whenever he speaks out of turn this
episode and in the season premiere so
he's actually behaving a lot like the
character of Claudius from Hamlet
Claudius was Hamlet's uncle who murdered
his brother the king and took his place
potties is totally driven by his fear
that his brother's ghost could come back
and get vengeance on him and this is
obviously similar to urine here he
murdered his brother Baylon and stole
the crown from his nephew Hamlet I mean
Simba I mean sorry it's a very common
story actually I mean just to stretch it
a little bit more I don't think it's a
total coincidence the white kind of does
look like Iran's brother bail on they
got the same hairstyle now we'll get to
this Shakespeare connection with Cersei
and Jaime in a second but first we want
to take a moment here because guys we
just can't do these videos for free so
we want to give a big thanks to a way
luggage for sponsoring it both of us
travel a lot and this is a totally true
story many Game of Thrones videos were
worked on in airports I don't know why
so no I can't remember for $20 off the
suitcase visit away travel calm / new
rock stars and use the promo code new
rock stars during checkout also the
suitcases themselves are awesome my
favorite things right up the bat
underneath the handle there's a freaking
USB port you can charge your cell phone
tablet you eat here anything else it's
hard but USB you charge this thing one
time and it can charge your phone five
times it's so you don't have to use that
awkward like stand-up thing - everyone's
crowding around in the airport you can
try it out 100 day trial and then you
get to know it you know go beyond the
wall with it if you don't like it you
can return it full refund no questions
that yeah again just visit away travel
calm / new rock stars and use that promo
code new rock stars during checkout for
a $20 office suitcase okay back to jaime
and cersei shakespeare influences yeah
they're inspired by Antony and Cleopatra
that's the relationship that was one of
the greatest romantic tragedies yeah
kind of happening again right here
Antony was a Roman war commander with a
one of Shakespeare's most complex and
divisive female characters like Cersei
she was both scorned and loved by
audiences so Cleopatra does a lot of the
things stuff sir she does she makes
Antony jealous with another man and
eventually after a series of military
defeats on her behalf Antony turns
against her it's just like what's
happening between them this episode yeah
a military commander suffering on the
battlefield for this toxic queen who
makes him jealous with another guy
you're on and there's actually some
other parallels too but it's starting to
feel like they're doing it so on purpose
that it would be potential spoilers
between what's gonna happen with Cersei
and Jaime so we're not gonna go into it
but you're always welcome to read Antony
and Cleopatra story it ends as a tragedy
like a lot of Shakespeare stuff stuff
yeah let us know what you think about
this parallel in the comment but there's
another interesting element about this
whole Cersei Jaime's scene that we want
to mention this scene is actually the
second half of their scene that we saw
in the other Jaime for that sort of
directed episode the first episode of
the season yeah the two seeds are
actually mirror images of each other the
beginning and end of one long
conversation between them over this
whole season notice how the blocking is
parallel with each one arriving to and
leaving the other as they stand alone on
the giant map and they're circling back
to the same exact debate points Jaime is
still incredulous that thirsty refuses
to even consider alliances while Cersei
is again lecturing Jaime about their
father and what he would have done I
think I listened to father for 40
and learn nothing you should have
listened more when father spoke about
the importance of gold now but that's
what is doing this to show how Jaime has
changed first he could tolerate Cersei
stubbornness when it was just the two of
them against a world specifically that
moment where he finds out about her
pregnancy that changes everything for
him suddenly Jaime is drawn to this
promise of having a real genuine out
there in the open future with his family
yeah but now Cersei is telling him that
despite that baby on the way her
survival strategy remains the same to go
it alone doesn't even matter to her what
world she's bringing this child into
basically at the beginning of this
season Jamie believes that just like any
good Lannister she is putting her family
before all else and here at the end of
the season he's realizing she's putting
her own interest beyond any sense of
family be it her baby or him yeah and
notice what he says to her here I don't
know that has two meanings right he
doesn't believe that she'll kill him
obviously but he also cannot believe
that she is this too far gone with her
pride you know it's fitting that the
scene ends with the snow falling into
King's Landing obviously that means that
winter is here but it also reflects sir
she's kind of emotional state now like
not to get too frozen a with it but
essentially she's like the ice queen now
yeah she has lost when we said earlier
is the last bit of her heart and now
it's frozen over mmm just like King's
Landing oh definitely and meanwhile
Jamie's separating from Cersei and
heading north to face a night king seems
like it could be a step in the direction
of that theory that we brought it before
that Jaime could be is her hi slash the
prince that was promised the saying this
episode did feature the image of a hand
on fire we did a video on this you want
to just go watch it yeah instead let's
move on to Westeros is new incestuous
power a couple John and Danny yeah this
whole season has been gradually bringing
them together in this episode finally
sealed the deal as bars actually began
back at the dragon pit notice how it
Daenerys and John are passing back and
forth that tiny dragon jawbone as you do
when you're flirting with someone and
discussing their fertility so yeah it
not only was it a symbol of death giving
way to new life the dragon bone actually
represents the child that Dany just lost
an Assyrian she's worried about having
no children to leave behind right now
turns out John might be the answer to
that and then later Daenerys the
decision to join John via boat and then
go on foot
winterfell takes the form of this
meaningful line we sailed together okay
we get it Daenerys you're all about that
ship relationship I know finally when
they come together the show is deciding
to shoot this in a very like pulled out
way where they're not being sexy like
they are having a very intimate moment
you see it very much in their eyes we
don't have that like pan gripping a hand
moment and they're like heaving boobs
for whatever evening well this show is
famous for shooting things that way and
this one was shot very straightforward I
think it's because it's a very little
like on the surface thing that is
happening here with these two houses
colliding which is why I think they did
that awkward intercut with Brian and Sam
Tarly just talking about his true origin
that being the son of Rhaegar Targaryen
Lyanna stark and Danny's freakin nephew
they wanted it to be obvious like the
facts of this moment are what matter a
little bit more than how sexy it is or
is it also it's obviously an overt nod
to the episodes title the dragon in the
wolf with both of these dragon wolf
pairings declaring love for each other
at the same time but then also the
creators of the show said that they
didn't want Daenerys and John's Union
here to feel like a clear victory in
fact no one in this episode gets a clear
victory well maybe the knight King does
at the end but everyone's hands are
dirty
yeah instead they want the moment to be
bittersweet like there's definitely
obviously negative consequences coming
for this just like there was the last
time a dragon and a wolf got together in
film oh yes now question here why did
Liana truthinator vehicle now we've
already talked about how this is awkward
there already was an egg on Targaryen
who was killed but this actually isn't
the most bizarre event from a historical
perspective there is precedent in
Scottish family lineages to reuse the
name of children who died young ages
actually shout out to Kelly Lawrence on
Twitter for sharing that with us also
there are other examples in our modern
royalty George Foreman names all his
kids George so that worked out fine
that's the King George in England right
now really the name Aegon connects John
to his Targaryen ancestors obviously
Aegon the Conqueror whose footsteps
Daenerys has been following this season
but more recently Aegon v technically
John if he were crown would be egg on
the sixth that Aegon by the way was the
mad Kings grandfather which technically
would make him Don's great
grandfather yeah that was the egg that
master Aemon of the Nights Watch was
calling for on his deathbed hey a dream
oh he actually did spend his last
moments with a Targaryen kind of named
egg little egg snow now one last point
about this the actor plane Rhaegar
Targaryen is wilf scolding a lot of you
actually pointed out how much he looks
like Viserys but that is by design yeah
it's not that Rhaegar just happens to
also look like Miss Eris remember
Rhaegar was like a celebrity so his
little brother Viserys is gonna grow up
trying to emulate Vegard look yeah it's
just we had a negative connotation of
this look because our first impression
of it was from this poser call him that
to his face let's quickly check in with
the on this episode his dialogue with
John and the dragon seven throne room is
filled actually with religious
undertones if you're following it hang
there with us for a second yeah notice
how this all follows the beats of a
confession the things I've done so my
place to forgive you for all of it but
what I can't forgive I do John even if
Oaks The Lord's Prayer first I get how
father
they really are setting up a spiritual
moment here that ultimately gets to the
rebirth outside on the beach he washes
his face in the waves he's recreating
both his drowned God moment that almost
saw like a Christian baptism yeah
Theon confessed his sins washed him away
and now he wants to start anew on this
new mission to rescue his sister and
redeem himself it's also interesting how
John brings up the idea that beyond
doesn't have to choose between being a
great or historic he can have both
because that's very much the exact
situation he's about to find himself in
but yeah he's right he can choose to
embrace the better parts of both
families that have made him into the man
he is today how about we move on to
Winterfell so this was a big deal it's a
little finger met with Sansa in private
and he does a couple of interesting
things here yeah notice how he turns his
wolf figurine on the mantel for himself
this represents the position that
Littlefinger has put himself in he
thinks he's in control manipulating each
young wolf in the direction he wants
them in without realizing that he has
left them with their open jaws pointed
directly back at him he also tries to
cast doubt on Arya's time with
men with the line I never trust godly
man it's an overall fear of faith in
general that we've actually seen from
Littlefinger before the member in King's
Landing the faith militant have taken
over
oh right that was the last time we
visited Kings Lane and he realized that
these people driven by religious
zealotry are the most incorruptible by
his political manipulation supposedly it
actually also applies to a brand right
because bran is kind of up God or godly
man yeah that's right he possesses the
powers of the old gods the children of
the forest that give brand these
supernatural abilities that pose really
the biggest threat to Littlefinger it
just seems like a purpose of this whole
thing has been a setup for Littlefinger
representing the old style playing the
game of Thrones and now it's been
overtaken by freakin like God issues and
supernatural forces this is not a play
for him to just any longer yeah also
Littlefinger plays this game with Sansa
which takes the form of a Q&A session
where Santa has to assume the worst
about Arya I assume the worst what's the
worst reason they could possibly have
for saying what they say and doing what
they do and I ask myself how well does
that reason explain what they say and
what they do yeah and this is
interesting because last episode
remember Sansa played a similar human
Aria the game of faces I asked you a
question about yourself and you tried to
make lies sound like the truth if you
fool me you win if I catch a lie
you lose yeah both those cases the
interrogation game actually reveals to
Sansa kind of more about the person
that's like putting the game upon her
like it Arya's game is clearly just try
to seek truth on the person's face kind
of thing yeah well little fingers games
like the opposite it's like pretend the
truth is not part of it let's color the
truth right away which is little fingers
hole I'm up yeah and that leads us to
little fingers surprise trial that was
amazing facial expression teammate which
let's be honest guys is not a fair trial
at all like in the world of Game of
Thrones no trial that we've seen at any
point it's truly just due process and
that starts trial obviously it's very
unfair yeah either of Tyrians trials
which both had to settle through trial
by combat
Cersei and Loras had their thing of a
trial that never happened because they
all burn to death but in this case the
three stark children are literally
judged jury and executioner re actually
reaffirms these roles in a late
I'm just the executioner you pass the
sentence and I would say that brain
actually also plays the role of a
witness in the right way all right as
the thread Raven he knew about little
fingers hold chaos is a ladder moment
but also when he convinced life there
and to poison her husband and blaming
the Lannisters the lie about the cat's
paw dagger he saw the whole thing yeah
and it's interesting when you think
about it this episode brand realizes
that the two recent major wars in
Westeros is history Robert's rebellion
the world of five kings were both based
on line actually we watching the whole
season you'll find all these moments
that foreshadows brands surveilling
Littlefinger this entire time every
single time we kept pointing this out
you see him on screen Littlefinger you
heared the sound of a raven CAW
now Brandon Arya deliver the punishment
a little finger Arya uses the same
dagger that Littlefinger sent to attack
Brando yeah this is reciprocal
punishment it reminds me of that idea
that we brought up of Queens Justice
earlier this season right Cersei
administered the Queen's justice on
hilarious and killing her daughter the
same way that a lawyer had poisoned
Circe's daughter so it's interesting to
see the stark girls reflecting Circe's
creative approach to justice right like
although they hate her they have learned
that there is satisfaction and
effectiveness in the way Cersei handle
things another parallel we talked about
this season between Sansa and Cersei is
their appearance on the first episode
Santa had styled her hair the way that
Cersei did previously so talk about the
Wardrobe choice in this episode let's
dive one last time into Game of Thrones
fashion roundup
so right after the scene with Santa
Marion Circe's Queens justice notice how
we cut directly to Cersei and who is she
wearing fur Cersei is dressed in the
type of clothes that Sansa would wear
okay
it's not just like the Queen using
fashion statements to make political
statements up back in the dragon pit you
can see how Danny switched back to her
crimson red cape that she was wearing in
the first episode yeah after several
episodes of her wardrobe becoming
increasingly gray to reflect her
shifting allegiance to Jon and now she
chooses to evoke the fire and blood of
her Targaryen family with the colors
once worn by her brother Viserys by the
way my favorite wardrobe choices episode
actually was barely noticeable it's on
this Dothraki bloodrider look at him
he's got a golden like crescent shape
piece hanging from his neck it's a piece
of a Lannister helmet he's wearing a
freaking trophy from
battle the black water rush to the
meeting with the Lannisters yeah and I
love on the camera when it cuts away
from you can see one of the lynnster
soldiers gawking out of his jaws drop
okay returning to orient answer briefly
though they actually share this moment
here where they quote their father the
snows fall and the white winds blow lone
wolf dies at the pack side the two stark
sisters had actually been standing in
for ned stark at Winterfell all season
long dance has been exemplifying Ned
wisdom his honor as justice Arya is
actually the one who swings a sword
after the sentences back together they
represent the two halves of their father
now let's move on to this final epic
sequence at the wall whoo okay well this
all takes place remember inside brans
vision which is actually a callback to
the way this season began remember with
brands terrifying vision of the
approaching army of the Dead so we
looked at this and we actually found
this very familiar to us it was shot in
the same way as a big battle from the
season even those two things that they
battle but if you go back and watch the
Blackwater rush battle from episode 4 it
begins with the infantry and cavalry
invading and then it's followed by a
boom surprise dragon soaring in from the
dark clouds above we think that there's
a reason why they're trying to make
these two things feel similar yeah
earlier this episode John makes a
similar comparison here general you
can't negotiate with an army that
doesn't leave corpses behind on the
battlefield the show is trying to
establish that the night king is no
longer just a supernatural threat he's
another formidable army in general
leading that army right like he's the
ice zombie equivalent of someone like
Tywin Lannister
this season made him look like more of a
war tactician than we've ever seen him
before and actually a lot of you guys on
Twitter are asking us what his
motivation is and that's what award
general really needs right they actually
set that up earlier in the episode with
the idea of bran saying what do men
fight for so you know you could be after
the Iron Throne like everybody else but
I could see that this thing with the
night king we don't know yet but it
could be more personal to him yeah we
brought up this theory before that the
night King might simply just want
revenge against the children of the
forest for creating him and dooming him
to these thousands of years of torment I
actually think that his destination
might be the Isle of faces in the gods
eye where it's rumored some children of
the force may still be alive honestly
whether or not the show intends to
answer this question of his motivation
it is making this promise here
the endgame is gonna look a lot like
what the show's always been from the
last seven years whatever the series of
conflicts between very shrewd very
deadly figures yeah it's going to be
strategic well-thought-out interesting
battles till the very end
now the collapse of the wall is
obviously a huge deal we went to all the
details of that in our game changes
video here I just want to point out the
look of these ice chunks as a
thunderously smashed into the sea these
visuals are modeled on real-life
glaciers and ice shelves that have
cracked and fallen into the ocean right
it's that footage of a tennis show when
they talk about there's another sign of
global warming how climate is changing
they always use a ice shelf Boeing yeah
that's what the wall is trying to
produce the similar sense of just dread
about what's gonna happen to our world
yeah also the wall falling is one of
those and never gonna happen event that
the season premiere actually
specifically for shadowed with
archmaester EEB roses assurance it's the
same in the Citadel thousands of years
before that during the long night we can
forgive them for thinking it truly was
the end but it wasn't none of it was the
wall stood through it all every winter
that ever came has ended so by ending
the season this way this show is
suggesting that this might be the
beginning at the end of it all and this
long night may never end okay
I was heartbroken with vissarion's death
but can we talk about he's pretty badass
now that he came back as this white
dragon or a lot of you guys have
different differences of it I liked it
no one's calling him an ice dragon
because that's not what he is but let's
take a closer look his wings now have
holes in them like the flesh has already
begun to rot away is war also did you
catch that yeah it transformed into this
like high-pitched screech yeah this is a
lot like the White Walkers sound once
the corpses get resurrected they have
this monstrous way let's kind of like
the show's sound of death I think the
most interesting thing then we got a tie
off with this new dragon it's blue fire
why is it blue okay at first it's kind
of like how why did it biology change
they add food coloring some people are
comparing this blue flame to
oxy-acetylene torches which are also
blue and way hotter than normal fire
which might explain why the flame could
have burned straight through the wall
right flame that burns hotter is blue
but
we've Devils in holdin on to it this
idea of like the real chemistry of the
dragon in fact the bigger question is
how can this dragons still breathe fire
at all we saw that moment when he got
hit his fire-breathing capabilities look
like they should have been done so maybe
this isn't fire at all this could be the
night Kings magic yeah obviously when he
creates White Walkers their new life
force is displayed with their eyes
glowing blue so whatever that magic or
energy is that's probably the same force
that this dragon it's now blowing on the
wall which would also explain why it's
like a million times more intense of
course also it could be that they were
like what if it flew now that's cool now
check out this overhead shot of the army
of the Dead passing through where the
wall once stood now as we wrap up here
let's squeeze in one last quick round of
a-ok these thousands of soldiers form an
interesting shape right facts I love you
have appointed us out it looks like the
night king sigil right which also kind
of looks because of the sphere which
would be the visual call by potentially
to the way that he got his new
game-changing weapon but I like thinking
it's just the sigil and leaving zoom in
enhance that was the entire team's
two-minute you really didn't even really
zoom this is a short we enhance we
didn't do either how about we talk about
the closing images what they mean so the
finale it's called the dragon in the
wolf right right so the episode showed
us what happened to characters who
selfishly go it alone like dragons right
little finger has definitely been on his
own throughout this whole season smugly
trying to impress his power over the
stark sisters and yeah that led to his
downfall
Cersei refused to form real alliances
instead planning to double-cross these
freaking people even when it doesn't
serve the interest of her family which
is why she suffers the loss of her
brother meanwhile the characters who act
like wolves putting the pack first
sharing resources and responsibilities
they succeed so for example Sansa and
Arya set aside their differences to make
their family a priority so that the pack
can survive also surprisingly new to the
way of the wolf
Jaime's he saw how Circe's rationality
wasn't in the interest of their pack or
their family so he left her to join up
with a new pack probably giving his
unborn child a better chance of survival
than the kid
anyway beyond of course also exhibits
sort of a pack mentality he forges this
new path for himself that leads to him
reuniting with his sister hopefully and
help this is a stretch but even the
night King is kind of a pack animal this
episode he could fly that dragon over
the wall just go it alone being a dragon
torch seen every castle he comes across
instead he brings down the wall so that
his pack and follow him and they can all
stay together
sure kinda but this episode is is really
about what happens when characters show
both of the qualities like they're
acting in self-interest like a dragon
but in doing so they also are trying to
create a pack like a wolf yeah that's
why they show us these two pairings of
dragons and wolves who do just that
Rhaegar and Lyanna and an heiress and
John in both cases they create something
beautiful something the world needs but
they pay a heavy price for it right
Rhaegar Liana dragged thousands of
people into war with their love they
toppled a freaking dynasty so we'll see
if their son and heir is gonna face the
same consequences for uniting the Dragon
and the wolf that's what happens when
you do that yeah do you think Tyrion is
hiding anything from Jon and Daenerys
let us know in the comments will Jamie
face similar justice from the Starks if
he comes to wonderful Brian is there he
hurt bran and really now that season
seven is over guys was there anything
you wanted more from this season was
this the third act payoff that you were
hoping for they'd leave something for
season eight though - right just let us
know all of those answers down in the
comments I or also you can tweet at us
yeah you can hit me up at EA was at fimo
also at new rock surges in general
especially with the hashtag Westeros
weekly we're gonna keep looking at it
forever and please you liked this video
share it to other people that are Game
of Thrones fans imagine the gift you're
giving them watching his entire season a
breakdown it's really been so much fun
to break down Game of Thrones season 7
with you guys actually plan to keep
turning out more Game of Thrones content
throughout the year season 8 predictions
Theory videos right you guys can also
help us out by making a contribution on
patreon over the summer we're really
trying to expand it to something huge
and we're really excited to do it big
thanks to all of our current donors
especially my man Alan Fleming thanks
man
alright guys thanks for watching bye bye